his evolution as a revenge seeking
villain criminal mastermind
and even occasional anti-hero has made
him a unique
and multi-layered villain no matter what
his scheme happens to be
baron zemo has always believed in one
thing that he was destined
to rule the world helmut zemo's father
heinrich was a ruthless but
brilliant nazi scientist who built a
death rate to help conquer the world
only to be thwarted by the howling
commandos this blow to his reputation in
germany
led to him disguising himself with the
now famous purple cowl
heinrich went insane when captain
america beat him again
and his cow was permanently stuck to him
thanks to his super glue invention
adhesive
x zemo gained revenge when he
booby-trapped a rocket whose detonation
put cap in suspended animation by the
time of avengers number 6 heinrich
created the masters of evil as a way of
trying to kill cap and his friends in
the avengers once and for all
zemo died when his death ray caused a
slide that buried
him while fighting cap in avengers
number 15. years later a villain in a
bright orange and red costume who called
himself the phoenix
not to be confused with x-men's phoenix
menaced cap
and his partner the falcon in captain
america number 168 the phoenix revealed
himself to be heinrich zemo's son helmut
having reverse engineered how to make
adhesive x and the death ray
at that time helmet zemo was no match
for cap one on one
and cap himself was reluctant to fight
him seeing helmut as
another victim of the war at one point
helmut who obviously survived his fall
into a vat of adhesive x married a woman
named haika
who initially claimed to be the
reincarnation of heinrich zemo by way
of the biofanatic arnhem zola in the
pages of captain america
haika was married to helmut zemo with 25
children they had stolen from abusive
family situations that they referred to
as
the kinder the zemos gave them love and
care while also making sure that they
were raised to hate captain america
haika was working with the evil
scientists superior whose agenda was
creating a world of super-powered women
and wiping out men
helmet overheard her scheming and had to
be talked out of killing her before he
fell into yet
another vat of adhesive x with haika
jumping in after him
cap wasn't going to fall for the same
trick twice and tracked them down
easily capturing them both this wasn't
exactly helmet's finest hour but it was
his most vulnerable
and he later claimed that his wife died
in prison
after his earlier schemes didn't work
helmut started hiding in plain sight in
order to get what he wanted
this was most famously revealed in the
pages of thunderbolts which featured
members of the masters of evil disguised
as superheroes in the wake of the
avengers disappearance and disillusion
and avengers the masters of evil
betrayed you
may the mockery of you zemo's disguise
as a descendant of the golden age
superhero citizen v
was especially delicious since his
father had killed the original
his plan was to make the public and the
authorities trust his team
then get access to shield and avengers
access codes in order to hook up a mind
control
device to a satellite his plan almost
worked but he hadn't accounted for some
of the thunderbolts actually wanting to
become heroes
and they led the resistance against him
after just a few issues
after zemo was seemingly killed by
scourge his consciousness was
transferred into the body of john
watkins iii
who had taken up the mantle of citizen v
in the pages of thunderbolts number 45.
he led the v battalion under the nose of
every other superhero
including the avengers a few issues
later he was offered a chance to lead a
team of government-issued superheroes
called the redeemers who were based on
the original thunderbolts
the point where helmut zemo really
became a master villain was avengers
number 273
when he launched his plan to monitor the
avengers probing for weaknesses and then
invading avengers mansion in observing
the team he saw that hercules chafed
against the wasp's leadership
that the black knight was infatuated
with the wasp and devised a scheme to
neutralize monica rambo
who was captain marvel at the time when
he learned that namor left the team he
struck
he had his best lackey the fixer created
device that allowed him to control the
dark force wielding catatonic named
blackout
that control disposed of captain marvel
and kept the other masters of evil in
line
including the devious moonstone he
brought in the entire wrecking crew mr
hyde
and goliath to act as his muscle they
beat hercules nearly to death
and did the same to poor jarvis all to
torture captain america
ultimately he failed not because he
didn't have enough power but because he
didn't believe his own analysis
he said the avengers always won because
they were unified but he treated every
one of the masters as expendable cannon
fodder
the avengers on the other hand fought
for each other because of the
friendships they had forged together
that lack of unity and the way he used
others was frequently his undoing
helmut zemo was obsessed with his father
and his legacy for many years
when captain america reappeared this
twisted his grief for his abusive
father's death into something truly
warped
like his father he wasted his own skill
and intelligence on futile revenge
schemes and recreations of destructive
weapons
the reality is that his endless crusade
for vengeance was his way of trying to
make his father proud
helmut even went so far as to try to
resurrect his father using fragments
from the magical bloodstone in the pages
of captain america number 357
all that did was put the essence of an
evil force inside heinrich's body and he
rewarded helmet by trying to kill him
helmet's obsession with legacy continued
when he went back into the past and met
all of his ancestors with their dna
being a focal point that allowed him to
go
into his family's past as he tried to
return to his own time
this story covered in the miniseries
zemo born better included a meeting with
his dad as he was demonstrating his
first death ray to hitler by this time
helmut was sick of how his father had
warped him
and they got into a fight helmut left
him the famous purple cow as he felt
himself pulled forward to the future
understanding how limited his father's
worldview actually was
zemo's time as leader of the
thunderbolts changed him even if he
didn't
want to admit it it took a while for him
to change but when he and the
thunderbolts were shunted off to
counter-earth in thunderbolts number 62
he learned to accept this adulation
even if his goals of world domination
didn't change
when the thunderbolts went to
counter-earth zemo was still sharing his
consciousness with the fixer
when zemo realized that the
counter-earth version of his father was
trying to take over the world he
directed the fixer to download his
consciousness into that world's version
of himself
who went by the name iron cross after he
killed this other version of his father
once again daddy issues he joined with
the thunderbolts who wanted to save the
world
zemo realized that as far as he was
concerned if saving the world meant
people giving him what he wanted
he was all for it zemo was hailed as a
hero for helping the survivors of the
world to the point where he started to
become uncomfortable with his adulation
when a threat to counter earth came
along he was ready to destroy earth in
order to save it but the thunderbolts
found a way to save
both planets in thunderbolts number 75
zemo went back to earth having convinced
even hawkeye he was a hero
for a long time helmet saw captain
america as the sole reason his life was
so lonely and meaningless
and as the reason for his father's death
of course it didn't happen that way but
helmut refused to listen
instead zemo made things personal in the
pages of captain america he kidnapped
cap's childhood friend arnie roth
and also kidnapped a pacifist friend
named dave cox
and turned him into a killer when he
conquered avengers mansion
zemo gleefully tore up photos of bucky
and cap's mom
and had mr hyde destroy cap's first
shield
then in avengers number 275 he had hide
beat jarvis to a pulp as
cap watched helpless
captain america it's been a long
time later when zemo had the kinder he
remarked on how much time he had wasted
hating cap and how much happier he was
with his family
of course he made sure his children were
raised to hate his rivals so that hatred
was still there
after zemo became a hero on
counter-earth and returned to earth he
jumped in front of a blast meant for cap
and saved him in the pages of avengers
thunderbolts number six
leaving him scarred once again things
got extra weird later when captain
america was changed by the cosmic cube
named kobik into a version of himself
who had always served hydra
this version of capp believed that
helmut had been his lifelong friend
and he even managed to talk helmut into
believing it
zemo has always liked having minions and
teams to do his dirty work but he values
absolute servitude above all else
you may call me master now kneel before
me
in avengers number 277 he made sure to
have the fixer give him
absolute control over blackout in order
to make him his personal bodyguard
in thunderbolts number 11 he used the
device called the bio
modem to take over the minds of the
avengers and was nearly able to take
over the entire world with it
one of the main reasons he kept
moonstone around was because of her
psychological acumen
which he could use to manipulate his
masters of evil
on a personal level he took over the
bodies of john watkins iii
and helmut zemo of counter-earth
escaping death both times as he used
another person's body
despite his frequent reliance on mind
control zemo's natural charisma has
convinced a lot of people to work with
him
as thunderbolt's annual number one
proved for example he knew
just how to appeal to each member in
order to get them to join
the fixer was bored and needed problems
to solve and
zemo gave him that songbird was on the
run and needed someone to offer her
shelter so
zemo provided mach 1 was tired of being
a loser and zemo gave him a chance to
win
goliath needed to be someone's soldier
and you guessed it
zemo made that happen whether zemo is
presenting himself as a hero
or a villain his goal of domination has
never wavered he wanted to rule the
world and thought as a zemo he was the
only one
fit to do it unlike many villains he's
come astoundingly close to winning
several times
he almost took over the mind of everyone
in the world with the biomodem
and only his own overconfidence proved
to be his undoing
even when he seemed to be more heroic he
had the thunderbolts help assemble the
liberator a device designed to drain the
power of super powered individuals in
the avengers
thunderbolts mini-series it
theoretically would have been used
against terrorist threats and
supervillains but it left
open two major questions first what
would be done with the energy it
absorbed
second who would decide when and how to
use it
a test run had adverse effects on
several heroes and even a
well-intentioned
zemo was willing to allow for a lot of
collateral damage
when zemo later decided to take over
hydra in the pages of all new captain
america he recruited a kid named lucas
whose blood could sterilize human beings
his scheme this time around was to save
the world's future by sterilizing most
of the human race creating a quote purer
world
he was going to detonate a bomb in the
atmosphere that would affect all of
humanity and had a backup plan
involving fleas carrying the toxin he
was eventually stopped by captain
america sam wilson
and his trusty bird red wing check out
one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite marvel characters are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]